oh god how do people put the dry powder
like straight into their mouth
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and today we're going to be
reviewing as leah williams
what i eat in a day but first i want to
chat about my sponsor squarespace
because
i do know that a lot of people are
thinking about starting new projects and
new careers this year
and in 2021 a website is
kind of key so if you're not familiar
squarespace is an all-in-one platform
where you can build a website
blog online store or just use their
marketing
tools and analytics they have so many
awesome features that are perfect for
new entrepreneurs
so you can connect your site to all your
social media accounts to make sharing
content super easy
and they also have some awesome blogging
tools that i often recommend to a lot of
the bloggers that i coach
honestly i really wish that this kind of
support was available when i started
blogging like a decade ago
because it would have saved me so much
time and money
you can check out squarespace.com for a
free trial
and then when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain
and quickly you can check out my
disclaimer here on the screen so feel
free to pause the video
to read it or check it out in the
description below including a trigger
warning
also don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on an episode
all right so based on your feedback and
also for my own attempt at work life
balance
um i'm keeping these videos short and
sweet when i can
so i'm gonna be trying a slightly
different format here that
brings it back to basics and allows me
to talk
not only about the good and not so good
wellness influencers out there
but also put my dietitian hat on to
discuss gentle nutrition
and give some tangible eating tips i'm
also filming this well in advance to
give myself
and my editing team some much needed
time off during the holidays so
please do excuse if this what in a day
is not
as leah's most recent this one was
actually posted mid-november so
we are working with the most up-to-date
information that we have at the time of
filming alrighty let's get into it
i just like to eat a more filling and
fueling breakfast because while working
out i get
hungry really easily so i have some eggs
out i got some
sausage these are the johnsonville
original recipe i just get the regular
one
i got some yogurt out which doesn't
really need to be out right now but it's
fine so for bagels i really like
these by the brand dave's killer bread
these are their cinnamon raisin remix
bagels and i love these because they
have protein in them they have 11 grams
of protein in one bagel so this is like
normally you know what i like to eat in
the morning i may finish it all i
may only finish half i may finish you
know 75
it just depends on the day and i just
eat until i feel like i'm done once the
eggs are like
95 done i just kind of mix the sausage
in there and call it a day literally all
i do
is i cut the sausage into soup into
super tiny
pieces how is she cutting those sausages
with those nails
i would for sure cut something off and
something that i actually
wanted to keep like a finger something
that i need tears but a scratch
a scratch this definitely looks like a
pretty solid meal which
she does say is pretty important on days
that she's working out
otherwise she might get hungry halfway
through her workout
i love that she knows her body
and she also trusts it to tell her when
she's
had enough as she specifically says that
you know hey
she might eat half of it or she might
eat all of it she just eats until she
feels
done that my friends is intuitive eating
at its best so even though this may seem
like a lot of food for breakfast for
a lot of you watching and there is just
under a thousand calories
right here if azlia is eating in
response to her
hunger cues it's probably the right
amount for her
as for macros assuming that she eats it
all we've got in
47 grams of protein in this meal alone
from the eggs
the dave's killer bread the sausages the
cheese
and the yogurt she's also got some fat
in the butter cheese and sausages
and carbs in the bread and yogurt
now i would say that if she wanted to
balance this out a little bit and
boost up the fiber she could cut back on
the saturated fat by
swapping half of the sausage for maybe
some fruit
or even some plant-based source of fat
like avocado
let's see what else she has to say
alright guys so it's now been maybe like
25-30 minutes and i'm pretty much done i
literally
finished everything other than this
little piece of my bagel i finished my
yogurt but the bagel at this point since
it's been sitting out for so long it's
just like dry and chewy now so
we're just gonna take a little pass on
that
i'm literally full like my stomach feels
full which is exactly how i like to go
to the gym because the gym is like a 20
25 minute drive so by the time i get
there like my stomach is perfectly
filled for a workout
okay amazing um again this girl just
knows how to tune into her cues and she
also knows the benefit of
slowing down to enjoy her meal and eat
it more mindfully
so trying to take a solid 30 minutes to
enjoy a meal
is actually a really great way to help
train your brain
to figure out exactly what your body
needs to eat
man what i would give for like a quiet
peaceful 30 minutes to eat because
honestly motherhood has me eating
often like this
no but seriously we do know that it can
take about 20 minutes or so
for your stomach to communicate those
fullness signals
to your brain and so many of us
myself included whip through a meal
before that can really happen
so she also mentions that she knows that
while she feels pretty full right now
after 30 more minutes when she starts
working out
she's gonna be at the perfect state of
satiety for
her activity so it sounds like as leah
is
really good at collecting dietary data
both retroactive
and current to help determine how much
she needs to eat
before something like a workout i'm
going to be you know taking this
pre-workout again that i shared with you
guys in my last vlog this is in the
flavor
breezeberry i'm very much excited not
gonna lie like i feel like my stomach is
already
starting to get hungry but the good
thing about this pre-workout i don't
know for me personally i feel like it
kind of brings my blood sugar up
okay so i take a scoop and a half
because i'm really not addicted to
caffeine like that but
nothing caffeine related like does it
for me no matter how long of a break i
take
oh my god i um
i just i can't with putting dry powder
straight into my mouth
that i see these influencers do i feel
i feel like i'm choking a little bit on
my saliva just like thinking about it
yeah but anyways different strokes for
different folks if that's how you want
to
take your pre-workout but this
pre-workout is pretty standard stuff i
looked it up
it's mainly like caffeine with some
l-citrulline beta-alanine
l-tyrosine and l-theanine so
basically it's designed to give you a
boost of energy to help give you that
like
extra little push when you're in the gym
and we do have some research to support
l-citrulline beta-alanine and caffeine
for activity enhancement
l-tyrosine for responding to stressors
like exercise
and also a combination of caffeine and
theanine for their synergistic effect
on promoting cognition and attention
now these effects aren't a lot more
significant than what you'd get from
caffeine alone
but if as leah finds that it helps her
get the most out of her workout
i don't really think that it hurts i do
however want to note that a pre-workout
supplement
like this does not raise your blood
sugars
as as leah suggests there's actually
no carbs in it it does give you a jolt
of energy thanks to the 200 milligrams
of caffeine which
is the equivalent of one to two cups of
coffee
so that might be the sensation that
she's experiencing
but it should not replace food if you're
hungry
or carbs if your blood sugars are low
anyways let's take a look at her
post-workout lunch
all right so as far as what i'm eating
we need some bread whatever type of
bread you want i have this whole wheat
bread and to be honest with you i didn't
even mean to get whole wheat i wanted to
get like the butter bread but i
accidentally got this
along with that oh some banana peppers
oh i'm gonna drink some coconut water in
the process
just because but along with that i need
oh mayonnaise
got my avocado oh olive oil mayonnaise
looks like a avocado and i need some
tuna i was really about to shut my
camera in here
i'm gonna get two things of tuna because
normally i make more than one serving so
the next time around like when i'm
hungry again or want to make this again
like i just have
leftovers to use i'm going to eat these
two sandwich
i'm gonna eat these two sandwiches with
this yogurt and you know we'll call it a
day okay so first of all i love how
simple
real and accessible this meal is in the
world of youtube and social media
it's kind of nice to see a girl just
make a basic tuna sandwich with
basic mayo and basic bread and not feel
the need to
shove avocado or kale into everything
but i don't know having said that i kind
of would have liked to see some avocado
or kale
or spinach or tomatoes or salad or
cucumbers or honestly
any vegetable now as far as post-workout
fuel goes
yeah like this is pretty much exactly
what we want to aim for
we've got a solid amount of lean protein
from the tuna
plus carbs in the bread and yogurt and a
little bit of fat in the mayo
but we could definitely do with a little
more veggies
or fruit let's take a peek at dinner so
set that aside i put my pasta in the
pot i add my pasta water with some pasta
it actually like got into the cup but
it's whatever and then i add my shrimp
and my pesto this is what it looks like
and then i just mixed it together
and that's pretty much it all right guys
so i just finished making my food this
is my pesto pasta completed i just
shredded like some fresh parmesan on top
but i am so
excited to eat this and i'm also eating
my meal along with
some white crayon strawberry juice
so another really simple and fuss-free
meal
we've got lots of protein from the
chickpea pasta and shrimp
plus carbs in the pasta as well and some
fat in the pesto
now i would say again however that we're
missing out on that
produce and no that white cranberry
strawberry juice
doesn't really count in my books now
while there is some real juice
in it and of course lots of vitamin c
the second ingredient
after water before any fruit at all
is sugar so you're getting 23 grams of
added sugar
and not a whole lot else now for the
same amount of calories as the juice
she could have two cups of fresh
strawberries
which would supply vitamin c plus fiber
i would also suggest throwing a handful
of frozen greens in there
or she could add some zucchini pasta to
just kind of like beef up
that chickpea pasta again i
so appreciate the simplicity of this
meal and also that there doesn't seem to
be any explicit demonizing
of foods or food groups but for the sake
of getting in
all those little micronutrients and
antioxidants we could definitely
do with a little bit more veg all right
folks let's talk about azlia's day
starting with these stats and of course
trigger warning i'm about to talk
numbers so
you can of course skip ahead if that's
not supportive for you
so in this day ashley is consuming
around 2 500 calories
with 24 of those calories from protein
36
from carbs and 40 from fat so while the
fat is higher and the carbs are a little
bit lower than what is traditionally
recommended
i think that this is a pretty common and
on trend way to eat right now
and it's not like she's completely keto
or eliminating carbs or food groups or
anything like that
so if this feels good to asliya and
helps her stay satiated and energized
amazing this totally works great for me
now let's talk about what i like here so
first of all
i love how easygoing and laid-back she
is about food
her meals are approachable and
accessible and easy and fast
exactly how i assume that most busy
people actually eat
so it's really refreshing to see an
influencer put themselves
and their meals out there exactly as
they
are no filters no stylized b-roll
no expensive hard-to-find ingredients i
also love that she's
actually eating enough for a busy active
young woman
which is not something that i can
confidently say for
most people that i review on this
channel and also that we're seeing some
really awesome variety in her meals
with different kinds of proteins carbs
and fats
now let's talk about some simple
strategies that i think we could use to
optimize those meals and snacks
first of all considering that she is
getting a
solid amount of calories here i would
definitely
love to see a little bit more fiber and
definitely a greater breadth of
micronutrients and antioxidants
since her analysis suggested that she
was a little bit low
on actually most of the vitamins and
minerals and
just squeaked by on the lower end of the
recommended fiber intake
her saturated fat intake was also higher
than recommended
and i think that all of these things
could be mediated
very simply by just focusing on one
tiny little tweak adding in more fruits
and vegetables
now you know i'm all about adding foods
not taking foods away
so if we were to throw in a serving or
two of produce at each meal
or pop them in as snacks we would likely
feel
satisfied enough that we would probably
need less saturated fat in our day
so at breakfast this could mean swapping
some of that breakfast sausage for a
side of berries
at lunch we could mix the tuna with
avocado instead of mayonnaise
and maybe throw in some cucumber and
tomatoes on that bread
and then at dinner we could throw a few
handfuls of frozen spinach
or peas or something like that into the
pasta we could also round up the day
with some standalone snacks like an
apple banana or orange or we could cut
up some veggies and serve it with a
plant-based dip like hummus
lots of great ways to get in that
rainbow of color and of course
boost the nutrition in your day without
feeling deprived
finally i want to close off by just
briefly talking about my impressions of
as leah as an eater at first blush
clarifying that of course i do not know
her personally
and i'm really basing this solely from
watching her channel
for a week and specifically in this
video
now it seems pretty clear to me that as
leah has an intuitive and balanced
relationship with food
i don't hear her talking about food in
dichotomous terms
and she specifically calls out that she
eats what she's hungry for
and has no issue leaving the rest you
know she's mayo and bread and pasta and
butter all the things that are often
demonized by some of her youtube peers
and she does it all without really
having a second thought
seems like she just likes these foods
and they fuel her body well and she
feels good
and is assumedly in good health period
so in conclusion while i don't think
that as leah is the kind of youtuber
that you'd flock to for nutrition advice
since i haven't really heard her
explicitly give a whole lot of it
i do think that she represents a
much-needed glimpse at
what normal eating can be and is
and for that reason i would give her
channel a watch
all right folks on that note that is all
for me today
thank you again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video if you liked it
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below
on who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you